foreign
we will see representative groan for
who's missing
motion by word second by Schmidt
seeing none all those in favor
any
body wish anything re moved from the
consent agenda
foreign
discussion all those in favor
Mr terminals to be postponed I have two
are there any other
foreign
both items will need waivers for gel car
okay so we need a motion for the board
of Licensing for Alcohol and Other Drug
use professionals
and for the prescription drug
affordability board
you need a motion to postpone and Grant
waivers we'll move second
motion by Schmidt sucking by McGuire any
discussion all those in favor
regular agenda
utility pole attachment rules
yes sir um
let's see so this proposal is
implementing the One Touch Make Ready
program which is a requirement of the
FCC there are a number of legislative
intent and some clarity comments and
there's also a recommendation regarding
doing some legislation to fix some
issues between the puc and the
department relative to their rulemaking
Authority
but they have filed a conditional
approval and that has been received and
a waiver as well my apologies but
there's no F there's no FP memo on the
website if you're looking for one just
to summarize there are some issues with
some ambiguous terms pursuant to 541a1
rules must Implement interpret or make
specific a statute and there are several
places in this proposal in which there
are some ambiguous U.S terms that are
used but they are not defined these
terms are just reasonable
non-discriminatory and the phrase good
and sufficient cause
if you note the agency's cover letter
indicates that one particular section of
the rule I think that was
1303.13 is meant to implement
47 cfr1 and like I said that's an FCC a
federal program the agency thinks that
SB 88 from last session created a carve
out but the statue clearly directs the
agency to adopt the fcc's rules as the
FCC has adopted them but it also directs
the agency to do so via the 541a it
doesn't explicitly carve out the rules
from the requirements of 541a so it's
not clear whether or not that was
intended to be an exemption but um the
agency has noted that it's difficult to
comply with both 541a and the fcc's
rules and
that's kind of a high level summary if
you will of what's going on with the
proposal if you look the first set of
comments
are on page two of the linked PDF down
at the bottom of the page
and again this is around this phrase or
these sets of terms called just
reasonable and non-discriminatory so a
poll owner is supposed to to provide
terms of attachment that are just
reasonable and non-discriminatory but
the agency hasn't defined those there's
no broad criteria to know what that
means and that can lead to arbitrary
decision making so
um the the agency has noted that
everyone you know the stakeholders and
and all know what this what these terms
mean but they still haven't defined them
um I think the next comment is on the
next set of count comments are on page
seven and eight and this pretty much is
the same sort of comment the rule again
is saying that during the performance of
Make Ready work for good and sufficient
cause but it doesn't talk about what
that means
the same issue on page eight where
they're using the terms reasonable
opportunity and non-discriminatory basis
again we don't really know what that
means if someone's supposed to have a
reasonable opportunity is that one is
that one day is that five days we don't
know what that means
um on the bottom of that page as well
you'll see that's on the bottom of page
8 of the linked PDF there's a large
comment box letting you know that
section 13 of the rule for the One Touch
Make Ready program that is meant to be
implementing that Federal Regulation and
like I said earlier the agency thinks
that it SB 88 created a car about but it
the language doesn't state that it says
that department shall under rules under
541a implement the provisions of One
Touch make ready as adopted by the
Federal Communications Commission
but it doesn't say that they're
explicitly carved out from the
requirements of 541a
so um
and like I said earlier the agency has
indicated that it cannot comply with
both
same common is essentially on page 10 or
where the rule is using reasonable
opportunity or reasonably likely but
doesn't Define what the term reasonably
means
the last comment is is a very large
comment on page 11 of The Proposal
and um here we know that there's some
need to clarify the rule making
Authority and the jurisdictional Divide
between the puc and the department of
energy
you may be aware that house bill 2 from
the budget bill from 2021 established
the department of energy and transferred
the puc's functions powers and duties to
the Department of energy specifically
RSA 12
P11 stated that all of the functions
Powers duties records personnel and
property of the puc is replaced with the
authority of the Department of energy as
of July 1st 2021
and RSA 363 one states that the puc is
an independent agency administratively
attached to the Department of energy
pursuant to RSA 21g10
and so the chair of the puc still has
some Powers set fourth in 21 G9 but 21
G9 authorizes a commissioner of an
agency to adopt rules of an agency so it
looks like that the puc chair still has
rule making Authority and we're not sure
what the extent of that rule-making
Authority is we don't know where the
line is between the department of energy
and the puc so again this comment is
here to to summarize some of the issues
that we're seeing and that you may want
to consider some legislation to address
that
regardless the department interprets the
statute to only authorize the puc to
regulate and enforce rates charges terms
and conditions of poll attachments and
to hear and resolve complaints and so
while there may be some you know some
lack of clarity where the jurisdiction
exactly lies
it does appear that they do have
authority to go ahead and move forward
with this proposal
so that summarizes the the issues with
we have a request for
I don't know what you can say to polish
thank you Senator Reagan and members of
the committee I'm Susan Geiger I'm from
the law firm of Oren Reno and I
represent the New England connectivity
and Telecommunications Association or
necta
necta has submitted a letter this
morning in support of the letter that
was submitted by the department of
energy which seeks conditional approval
of the final proposal of the poll
attachment rules as indicated in our
letter we think that the the information
presented in commissioner chicoine's
letter
outlining the reasons why the
um the statutory Authority that Doe has
allows it to maintain the wording of the
rules that it has submitted is
appropriate and I'd be happy to answer
any other questions that the committee
might have
I'd also defer to attorney Wiesner who I
believe is going to speak to this issue
he represents the department of energy
okay so we'll hear from him to find out
why there's so many comments on these
rules
thank you
good morning uh Mr chair
um Madam Vice chair members of the
committee my name is Chris Elms I'm the
Deputy Commissioner of the New Hampshire
Department of energy and I'm joined by
attorney David Wiesner who's the legal
director for the Department
um the final proposal and conditional
approval request before you today are a
result of the Department's work to
reflect the restructuring that occurred
with the creation of the department uh
in hb2 last year
um this includes transferring many
functions from the puc to the department
including the rulemaking for utility
pole attachments we have made only
minimal changes to most of the existing
puc 1300 rules
um that will now be the utility pole
attachment rules of the department uh
the new Department of energy rules are
also intended to implement Senate Bill
88 which had many Provisions dealing
with Broadband expansion in that
legislation the general court directed
the department to adopt Federal
Communications commissions okay so what
are we going to do about all the
comments that about the vague words that
you've already known about and haven't
done anything about it in the
formulation of the rules I will let
attorney Wiesner respond to that
foreign
thank you excuse me for the record I'm
David Wiesner I'm the legal director
with the Department of energy uh and I
will address those issues so earlier
this week we filed a conditional
approval request we addressed the
editorial and formatting changes that
were noted by OLS comments we declined
to make language changes uh in
particular with the uh the language
which has been called into question by
the OLS comments again as Deputy
Commissioner Elms mentioned our intent
here was to make minimal changes to the
puc 1300 rules which are effectively
being brought over to the Department of
energy in connection with this
rulemaking and other than that change of
name if you will from one agency to
another our Focus was on implementation
of Senate Bill 88 passed last year which
we interpret as directing the department
to effectively adopt nearly verbatim the
rules of the Federal Communications
Commission regarding One Touch make
ready
we believe it's important to do that in
order to affect the legislative intent
to facilitate Broadband expansion in the
state by making it easier for new
attaching entities to install fiber
cable and other facilities on existing
utility poles
and I will note that in our rulemaking
process there was almost unanimous
support for adopting the FCC rules
nearly verbatim as I say in these State
rules consistent with that legislative
intent in Sp 88 so that was the decision
that we made with respect to the new
section
130313 which incorporates the One Touch
Make Ready rules into State rules and
the FCC rules not constrained by some of
the limitations that we see in the
rulemaking manual here include language
such as as reasonable and good faith and
so we incorporated that here I've had
this conversation with attorney Reeve
and we discussed a potential language
change that might be made in section
130301 A where there's a broad reference
to terms that are just reasonable and
non-discriminatory
and we do think that there would be an
opportunity there to remove that
language and merely reference the state
statute RSA 374 34-a
and if the committee would would
entertain that I might offer that as an
additional condition that might be
considered for approval this morning
with respect to the other language that
was called into question by the OLS
comments uh I will just offer that that
language appears in the FCC rules
and uh it and in in particular in
reference to section 1303 12 also uh
appears in the existing puc 1300 rules
which again we are just bringing over to
the Department of energy in this
rulemaking process
um I I will I will add perhaps some
Nuance to attorney Reeves comments on
1303 13.
I think in our view it is not possible
to both
um
to to accommodate the legislative intent
to incorporate the one-touch make-ready
rules of the FCC into these new energy
1300 rules uh and comply with the
rulemaking manual
because the FCC rules as I noted contain
the word reasonable in in a number of
places and we carried that over I think
our view is that we would not be
honoring the legislative intent to
incorporate those Provisions if we were
to drop that language uh in in strict
compliance with the rule making manual
so I I think our position is that this
is uh a place where variants from the
manual makes sense because it is not
possible to comply both with the manual
and with the more specific legislative
intent in SB 88 that that we deem as
requiring the department to adopt nearly
verbatim those FCC specifications
and the FCC rules I'll just note are
well understood by the regulated
Community as we understand it most of
whom are sophisticated
telecommunications carriers and you
heard from uh one of their
representatives this morning that they
support the rules as proposed
representative Gore
thank you Mr chair
uh attorney Wiesner I'm curious how you
interpret shall adopt rules under 541a
implementing the provisions of One Touch
make ready as adopted by the FCC as
incorporate the federal rules into our
rules
foreign
we believe the legislative intent was
for those One Touch Make Ready rules as
written by the FCC that's not what the
statute says
it says adopt rules under 541a
implementing the provisions of the One
Touch Make Ready rules
and I I believe that in cases of
question without specific other
legislative intent data that's what it
says implement the provisions our view
was that implementing the provisions
without the word reasonable would not be
go ahead
thank you Mr chair I guess this is a
question for for staff over there it
seems like our argument is around the
word just Regional non-discriminatory
and good and sufficient cause those
phrases are repeated throughout the
statute throughout the rule-making
authority and and I guess my my question
is absent a definition in the rule
aren't those you know going back to my
prosecutor those days those are pretty
clearly defined legal definitions to
begin with
um that they're easily found and easily
understood and if I follow up if I it
developed to represent Maguire's
question if the FCC rule contained the
word reasonable how can our rule not
contain the word reasonable if we're
supposed to implement their rule so I I
guess that's a two-fold question is it
seems like the legal definitions are
clear they've they've been they've been
adjudicated many times on those four
different words uh or phrases and
secondarily as if if they in did
incorporate the exact rule which would
contain the rain reasonable we'd have
the same problem so I guess I'm I'm not
I'm struggling to understand why we
would object to this okay so there are
two different places so one is the
statute 374 and it does use some of
these terms um just in
non-discriminatory and I believe it does
use good and sufficient cause I wouldn't
say that just reasonable or
non-discriminatory is well defined it's
certainly not defined in the statute and
so um as I said earlier rules are
supposed to make specific and Implement
and interpret the statute so the statute
doesn't Define it then the rule needs to
Define it
what one attorney may think means
reasonable another attorney made
disagree and think there's another
definition for the word reasonable it's
pretty squishy generally
the the second issue is on the word
reasonable as found in the FCC that also
I didn't see a definition in the federal
statute for that there could be one
but I didn't find one so we typically
you know recommend or we typically flag
these sorts of words because they
introduce ambiguity into the rule just
like I said earlier one attorney may
think that reasonable opportunity is
five days another may think it's 10 days
so it's it's up really to the agency to
Define what that means when the statute
doesn't Define it
so um I will point out that in the puc
proposal that the committee recently
heard they also use terms like just
reasonable and for the public good and
we had some conversation with them about
that and they said that it was um it was
essentially in case law and it was an
adjudicative process and so they did not
feel comfortable defining that so what
they ended up doing was talking to the
AG's office and then just referring back
over to the statute
so in my conversation with the
Department that was essentially what I
recommended and what he's proposing with
that first section or that first set of
comments that you see on the bottom of
page two so here instead of using the
terms just reasonable and
non-discriminatory they would just refer
back over to 374 34A
so I mean that would somewhat deal with
it
um it still leaves it up in the air as
far as exactly what that means
um I could point out that if the
stakeholders and the FCC if everybody
knows what these terms mean then they
should be able to kind of arrive at
something you know to Define it but it
may be that there is some disagreement
as to what those terms would mean and
they don't want to to do that here in
the rule
um to get back to the other point I was
making the the FCC rules are only in
section 13 and that's some of the FCC
requirements may be sprinkled throughout
but my understanding is that it's mostly
in section 13 here and that's where
they're using some terms around
reasonable
um
that section doesn't have those terms
just public good or
non-discrimination in this particular
section
hopefully that answers the question
Mr chairman yes in response to
representative Lang's question I I would
point out you know in regards to making
these comments uh staff is statutorily
obligated to raise any potential basis
for objection committee can certainly
disagree or even if it thinks there is a
basis for objection uh under the law
so just to make sure I understand where
we're sitting right now right now we
have a conditional approval request
they've made some preliminary language
changes that they based on the
objections of Staff in that first
section and that's what's presented him
before us right now for a vote
yes yes and it it well it sounds like um
so the the so they do have a conditional
approval that you're um that's on the
table and then they've also um suggested
some additional language in that first
section so it would be an amended
conditional approval assuming that the
committee is an agreement with that
language
I'm sorry
looking for an objection motion
Mr chairman since representative patch
is now in uh representative Gruen could
be appointed for Senate Apprentice who
is the only remaining member not here
Mr chair I'm going to move to approve
what the language suggestion number one
representative McGuire
yes thank you uh disregarding the other
issues I'm concerned that this doesn't
seem to repeal the existing puc rules
and I wonder if you would clarify that
for us
I I believe that
probably next month the puc will be
before you with their amended version of
the puc 1300 rules and that will remove
all of these sections that appear here
and retain for the puc only the
functions of dispute resolution and rate
setting so if you were to look at the
existing puc rules I believe it's
section 1304 will remain with the puc
and the definitions that go with it
meanwhile all of the other substantive
Provisions will be adopted by the
department of energy through these rules
and it is our intent to see that those
two sets of rules are new rules and
their amended rules will become
effective at the same time
that would be good having two sets of
rules at the same that were
in effect would be uh inconvenient
representative McGuire
um the notice number for that one is 20
22 55 I have reviewed the um initial
proposal and they do have comments so
I'd prefer that we object to this and
hash out these
language differences
so we have a motion on the table
that I will be voting no on
to approve the rule so all those
in favor
okay
motion by Schmidt to object second by
hatch
will they need a waiver
are we they didn't they would we would
need a label okay
no wait a second it's November it's
okay
all those in favor
thank you
and next on the menu Department of
Agriculture feeding garbage to swine
rules
thank you Mr chair
so
this particular rule there was a
conditional approval
request filed within the time limits for
this meeting
it was accepted and reviewed on the
website there is a cover memo for the
final proposal packet at the very bottom
we apologize that it's not with the
conditional approval response on the
website but it is there at the bottom if
anyone wanted to review that but the
remaining comments from the conditional
approval request
um is one unclear legislative intent
comment on page three and two notes to
um
commenting on the fact that the statute
has been effect since 1995 and this is
the first time that the agency is
proposing rules for this particular
section
the rules also
comment on an application fee which is
statutorily set in RSA 435 34 for a sum
of ten dollars
additionally for penalties reflected in
RSA 43540 it does state that any person
who violates the statute or rules if
they're any is guilty of a misdemeanor
it may have an administrative fine no
more than five thousand dollars levied
against them by the commissioner so the
statute does also cover penalties
without rules
with regard to the second note to jail
car it's just commenting that the agency
does have the statutory authority to
enter the premises of a licensee which
is reflected in their rules
the legislative intent unclear comment
on page three
has to do with these special permits
granted by the commissioner the way the
rule is currently written is that no
swine fed garbage that has not been
properly cooked or treated shall be
moved into or within New Hampshire
unless pursuant to special permission
granted in writing by the commissioner
at the commissioner's Soul discretion
this rule lacks criteria to
outline what exactly is considered when
a special perm permission is considered
by the commissioner in what criteria the
commissioner will make that decision on
which leaves room for oral rule making
which is prohibited by RSA 541a1
I have had some discussions with the
agency about specific criteria the
agency believes that
in the
Communications I've had with the agency
they have voice that they believe that
having criteria would be too
that the criteria considered is too
broad to actually be put into rules
um however there was some back and forth
discussion about potential
language that could be used as criteria
but no amended conditional approval
request was received so at this time
that comment is still standing
you turn it on
thank you uh Steve Crawford State
veterinarian New Hampshire Department of
Agriculture markets and food good
morning
so I
I the summary that you heard was was
accurate we there were a couple of
substantive comments earlier we we
yielded on one because we did not
believe that there would be any emergent
implications to approving other forms of
treating garbage in this particular
instance though the department thinks
that
just in time Disease Control flexibility
is necessary and we also think it's
already allowed in statute there are a
couple of pieces of statute
that that we believe cover the same
thing that is proposed in that 405 B
um
so Interstate quarantine
management decisions are authorized
under 436.35
that section actually uses May three
times doesn't use shell
so I believe we have that flexibility
already and we've seen with the high
path of influenza stuff we've been
dealing with this year that just in time
changes are kind of important for us to
be able to make the right decision
rather than having to go through an
emergency rule making session so
we're open to
to finding the language that that
maintains that latitude for the
commissioner to make just-in-time
Disease Control decisions and with again
conditional approvals that we're seeking
so does staff believe that you can come
um well Mr chair the agency did send an
email with some language that could
potentially be turned into a rule in my
opinion specifically that uh special
permission will be Grant shall be
granted when
I apologize special permission shall be
granted in the most efficient expedient
and effective way possible we're still
working on that language to get that in
a place where it would be
specific enough for criteria but also
broad enough to allow the agency some
discretion to deal with those time
sensitive issues
so it is possible that we could come to
foreign
yes I hear that Dr Crawford how often
does this come up is this a common
practice
the the asking broadly about garbage
feeding or asking specifically about
this interstate movement permissions
both um garbage feeding is a common
practice it's been authorized under
federal statute since the mid 80s and as
you heard the department has never
sought to implement rules because the
statute doesn't require us to have rules
it authorizes a commissioner to have
them when we think it's appropriate
we have seen over the last several years
and USDA has always done those
inspections for us
we have seen over the last several years
USDA pulling back its resource
allocation to the state so we think it's
appropriate the timing was appropriate
for us to have our own rules set
um in terms of
management of Interstate quarantines
several times a year probably
more in the last year with high path
Haven influenza but several times a year
we're making these types of decisions
about how to deal with something on a
so so several times a year someone
wishes to move garbage feds flying out
of well not of New Hampshire you won't
care it's into New Hampshire that's the
issue I I guess my apologies I was too I
was thinking quarantines broadly not
just quarantines related to this
quarantine's related to this uh
I don't recall the last time a
quarantine related to garbage feds fine
has come up but other livestock that we
have authority over several times a year
sorry
so if I understand you correctly
these special permission and writing is
extremely rare yes ma'am thank you
second
ocean by hatch second by McGuire it's a
conditionally approve
and encourage your consultation with the
staff I understood
any discussion
all those in favor
aye any opposed
Liquor Commission employee incentive
programs
um
so this um this set of rules would
Implement an employee incentive program
in which employees can get
um you know monetary incentive for sales
there's only one issue to talk about in
regards to these rules and you'll see
that on the first page of the rule set
which is on page four the linked PDF
so hb2 in 2011 established that the
agency May develop and Implement an
employee incentive program and it
required the agency to implement that
program via rules adopted through 541a
so this is the first time that the
agency has done any rules for this
program
in response to OLS comment about
implementing the rules or implementing
the program prior to adopting the rules
the agency has indicated that they have
not implemented the program at all the
committee may have some questions about
that
questions
are you here from the liquor committee I
am all right good morning my name is
James Vera I'm a CEO of the Liquor
Commission prior to that when they were
submitted I was a chief legal counsel
there any questions I'm certainly
willing to answer them I can say and
just concur that at the time and I
should say before I begin I'm dealing
with some hearing issues so if I have to
ask questions again I apologize to the
group
um this is the first time that the
commission has sought to implement the
program of which we're now asking for
rules to occur before that
so we've not started the program we've
come in here as we're statutory required
to test for rules uh happen
questions
motion by McGuire second by lying to
approve
any discussion
all those in favor
any opposed
Keno at Lottery retailers
and
thank you Mr chair this particular
proposal we also received a conditional
approval request for the conditional
approval request did address a number of
editorial comments and a couple
substantive comments however there are a
number of remaining comments
primarily due to statutory
conflicts as well as statutory
interpretation
looking at the conditional approval
request the first comment is a note to
jail car on page one regarding
the license requirements for a
retailer to operate Keno on their
premises
the rules reflect RSA to 84 46 3.
with regard to criminal convictions
specifically stating no person who has
been convicted of a felony or Class A
misdemeanor within the previous 10 years
which has not been annulled by a court
or Class B misdemeanor within the past
five years which has not been annulled
by a court or has violated any of the
statutes or rules governing charitable
gambling in the past in this or any
state shall be licensed
to under the subdivision
this statute is in conflict with RSA 284
5B which also prohibits an employee to
operate keno games if such person has
been convicted of a felony within the
previous 10 years however it does not
mention Class A misdemeanors
or Class B misdemeanors but rather a
misdemeanor involving falsehood or
dishonesty so there may be a need for a
legislative change with regard to those
statutes to make them more consistent
but at this time the commission is using
the more restrictive statute with regard
to that the second comment is an
authority comment at the bottom of page
one the rules specifically state that
the applicant shall have the ability to
meet Financial Obligations as
demonstrated by an established credit
history or a bond neither of these
requirements are reflected in statute
there is a statute with regard to the
commission being able to ask for
financial information after someone has
been licensed to operate a Kino machine
however there is nothing in the statutes
regarding their ability to do this when
an applicant is applying for this
license so there is a bit of a
potential issue with regard to their
authority to do that
the third comment on page two has to do
with the reference to
the license uh the applicant to sign a
agreement called the New Hampshire
lottery uniform retail agreement
retailer agreement excuse me
this agreement which was submitted to
our office primarily is made up of
requirements that are uniformly applied
to all retailers under RSA 541a
four this would be considered a rule
however the committee has taken varied
positions on this interpretation when
reviewing contracts like this one in the
past
for example this agreement also touches
on the sale of lottery tickets and has
actually been in effect under uh lot 300
the lot 300 rules however
these are new rules and they are include
they have included Provisions for Kino
machines specifically so I think it's
worth taking another look at it to
consider whether or not these
requirements should be placed in the
rule or if the commission committee
would just determine it as a contract
but regarding the agreement there are
also two issues with the agreement
itself which I will touch on later
with regard to
um
two Provisions in the agreement which
the commission may not have the
the next comment is on page four it's an
edit unclear comment about
um
the
applicant losing his um what
requirements the applicant may lose
their license
there are two statutory provisions of
which the applicant can have their
license revoked which are not reflected
in the rules the first is whether or not
they lose their liquor license after
submitting the application is one of the
requirements for being able to operate a
Kino machine is to either have a liquor
license or to sell lottery tickets on
the premises the other is um with regard
to the criminal convictions
um whether or not
um
someone has those criminal convictions
and as I stated there are conflicting
statutes with regard to what those
with regard to the next comment on page
five it's an unclear comments
um oh I apologize uh underneath that
there is a Authority legislative intent
comment with regard to another reason
that the licensing can have their
license revoked the commission
specifically put in the conditional
approval request that if the licensee
fails to comply with the terms of the
agreement
including failure to meet the minimum
sales requirement that could be grounds
for revoking the license however
uh there doesn't seem to be anything in
the statute requiring that a licensee
meet a minimum sales requirement on page
two of the agreement there is a note
that
the licensee would be agreeing to meet a
minimum sales volume of three thousand
four hundred dollars per week in Keno
sales and as I stated there's nothing in
the statute that specifically
requires that of a person who has a
license to operate a Kino machine
um so there is an issue with regard
to that particular provision the other
issue with regard to the agreement is
found on page six of the agreement it
says to have the keynote 603 terminal
available and operational for the sale
of Keno tickets and to have and to
redeem all Keno tickets during all hours
and days that the retailers businesses
open RSA 248 47 ones specifically states
that a person can only operate a Kino
machine between the hours of 11 A.M and
1 a.m so that agreement may be in
conflict with the statute if a retailer
has hours that they're operating outside
of that statutory requirement
um
on page five of the rules there is
another unclear comment uh regarding
hearings
the
commission specifically
um
sites RSA
284.50 or RSA 541 a 30
comma 3
as applicable for a licensee who is
requesting a hearing
um
there's an editorial comment that that
should be citing to RSA
541a32 but additionally RSA 28450 is
specifically refers to re-hearings and
does not refer to initial hearings
um and also states that the rehearing
shall be governed by 541 which is the
statute which allows
appeals to go to the Supreme Courts
under this rule um
the license he should be entitled to a
hearing and then a re-hearing within the
commission prior to be able to appeal to
the Supreme Court if the Supreme Court
is likely not to take up an appeal that
is not exhaustive all administrative
remedies so this rule is is a bit
unclear as written it seems as though
they need to have a site to either their
procedural rules for hearings or a
different statutory site
also on page five there's an unclear
legislative intent comments once again
commenting on the conflicting statutes
so do you have hopes that on a
conditional approval that you can get
all of this squared away
um so I apologize if I didn't make that
clear this is on a conditional approval
um and as I stated the conditional
approval did address some of the
substantive and editorial comments um
however with regard to the statutory
conflicts that's something that
obviously would have to go to the
legislator to change and with regard to
the agreement it does seem as though
that agreement is necessary for the
commission to
operate and rent out their machines have
their machines maintenanced and all that
so there are certain Provisions in there
that the committee should consider
when you know whether or not the
agreement can stand on its own or
whether or not can be incorporated to
rules those are issues that really can't
be
addressed just between OLS and so let's
hear from the agency and tell us your
plan
for rectifying
good morning my name is Valerie King I'm
with New Hampshire Lottery and I'm here
with me as my Superior John Conforti he
is the chief compliance officer with New
Hampshire lottery I'm going to let John
deal with some of the uh bigger issues
so thank you Mr chair
um so we've we've addressed I believe a
number of the comments uh that attorney
Rickard has uh brought up
um there are a few that we can address
because they're statutory in nature the
underlying statute itself has some
conflicts uh we have agreed and we do
plan to
um to work with the legislature in this
session to address those those issues
that's in particular with respect to
um the criminal background requirements
um for like who in the legislature are
you dealing with uh I I'll have to speak
with uh with the director McIntyre I
believe uh we are going to look at
actually removing the license fee as
well
um and I know I don't know if uh
representative Lange if we've had this
guy sessions with you yet I know we have
some ongoing discussions with members of
the legislature to get those ready for
this session
um but I don't know who specifically
director McIntyre is working with but I
know that that is uh underway
um can you get back to us online
absolutely absolutely
um with respect to
um the issue of asking for financial
information on the front end
um as we we said with with
um as we discussed with staff RC 28446
um allows the Lottery Commission to
review an application and either approve
or deny it uh 284 46 identifies very
specific reasons why we can deny an
application but it does not mandate that
we shall uh uh accept an application
um under all circumstances and we
interpret that to allow
um the commission to require some uh
some evidence of ability to operate
effectively that is based on the
statutory requirements as as attorney
Ricard said there are a number of
financial requirements that are on a
licensee during the terms of operation
what we have done as an agency is
request uh as part of the application
review process that they demonstrate
evidence of financial responsibility uh
obviously this is very important to the
commission because a retailer is
effectively retelling the state's
product they hold our money
um after a sale and before it gets paid
to us on a weekly basis
so it's critically important to us uh
that obviously that these uh entities
are financially responsible and we
believe that that is based on statutory
Authority that the legislature has given
us
um in 284-48
um that requires a number of financial
reports and financial
um requirements for licensees during the
course of operation and I'm sorry if I
could just step in very briefly and I
apologize for not bringing this up
before this comment was also made on the
conditional approval text from 2017 and
at that time the committee did approve
the language at that time
and I should I should have started with
this that um and we we discussed this
with attorney Ricard
um
we're bringing these rules forward
because the legislature changed to
expand the uh eligibility of Keno
licensing to retail environments
um and that's literally the only changes
that have occurred
um all the remaining changes that staff
has brought up that you know obviously
need to be addressed
um we're underlying in the rule since
2017.
um so this was a minor modification that
obviously has brought up staff obviously
has identified a number of issues that
need to be addressed
um with respect to the retailer
agreement we do have a
um what is essentially a retailer
contract
um that addresses all elements of
lottery sales and Kino is part of that
we would suggest and uh would ask that
the committee allow this to stand
outside of rules because obviously this
is in the nature of a business agreement
between a retailer and the lottery as
the wholesaler of these Lottery products
um and we need to be able to address
issues that come up in the course of
business quickly
um and we obviously they are subject to
your review because they are uh
referenced in here however
um we do need some level I think of
ability to make uh changes as business
conditions require
um on a faster basis
um and that's why we're asking that that
agreement remained outside of the rule
but only referencing the rules so that
we're able to change those as would be
required on a more expedited basis you
might want to consider that when you're
doing your legislative changes
go ahead
thank you Mr chair I have one question
the statute limits the hours of
operation for keno and this seems to
imply that they can it can be played at
the local convenience store 24 hours a
day yes thank you representative McGuire
I meant to bring that up on my initial
uh discussion so uh attorney Ricard is
correct however we actually the Lottery
Commission controls the game the hours
of the game the game is only available
between 11 and 1 a.m the reference to uh
allowing operation during all hours
um
we allow the sale of tickets for so for
example it is 9 55 we would allow
someone to buy a ticket for the first
draw but the draw only occurs at 11 A.M
and that is wholly controlled by the
Lottery Commission
um so the availability of the equipment
to sell is to sell four games that will
occur only during those hours and to
redeem tickets that have already won
um so with resp I understand
theoretically there's a conflict but in
reality we have complete control over
that game they are not operating the
game The Lottery Commission operates the
game they merely make it available
through terminals in their locations
foreign
thank you Mr chair just considering it
was my bill House Bill 355 that created
a little bit of this mess I'll be happy
to take responsibility for cleaning it
up
I'm sorry just just on the point of time
of sale
um why can that that not be put into the
rules for Keno expressly I understand
the system I understand you control when
they can and cannot be sold but
shouldn't that be uh stated sir
certainly I that's we can take that back
and and revise that I just I wanted to
point out for the committee that um that
is not allowing licensees to sell
outside of the statutory approach period
because sales are only permitted through
the lottery during that time period
however we can make that editorial
change
I think that's very important as part of
it's a conditional approval to to do
thank you
thank you Mr chair so your earlier
remarks with regard to being allowed to
uh operate outside the rules with regard
to uh
exigencies of business practices and so
forth and that is an awfully wide uh
Open Door it seems to me for uh
uh you know for oral rule making and so
forth and uh I'm I'm a little bit
once you're operating outside the rules
do basically do anything you want with
that uh star of uh business requirements
and so forth unless you can
confirm that uh it's not nearly as
loosey-goosey as it sounds so river is
that respect it's not nearly as
loosey-goosey as it sounds
um because it is it is referenced in the
rule it remains subject to your purview
I'll I'll let my rules expert explain
exactly
um the benefits that we would have but
you would certainly still have oversight
over that
um over that process
so I I assume you're referring to the
agreement the retailer retailer
agreement so that is incorporated as
part of the rule and it and it is part
of your package
um and it lays out the what they can and
cannot do
I'm not sure but I think he's uh so I
believe what you're asking is it it
wouldn't it would go through a more
expedited process in order to change the
agreement
um so we would not have to go through a
full rulemaking process but you would
still have oversight a jail car would
still have oversight over that process
let's get to that
go ahead
um
regarding the agreement if you feel that
it's a contract and it's outside
rulemaking then that's that's fine
um
but if you consider it to be a rule then
if they can't incorporate it by
reference in fact this agreement seems
to be created and please correct me if
I'm wrong buy the Lottery Commission and
you cannot incorporate by reference a
document that's created by or be on
behalf of an agents but if you
considered a contract then it's not an
issue
Mr do you have a question so considering
it as a contract versus a rule in this
in this context
that contract I assume is still subject
to oversight by the commission so the
Lottery Commission itself if there was a
change in this contract would have to
approve that so it goes through another
process besides shellcar the adjust any
changes is that correct
that's true we it would go through
commission and we have always I I
understand staff's comment but we have
always brought any changes to that
document because it is
it is referenced in numerous rules so
anytime we have edited that agreement we
have brought it before this committee
it's also dated
it's referenced by date in the rule
okay
any other questions we have a motion in
a second
um I I just wanted to add that with
regard to the references for hearings I
can make that correction as part of the
conditional I can reference our lot
rules that oversee hearings and make the
correction to the RSA
any further discussion
seeing none all those in favor of the
conditional approval I any opposed
thank you thank you I apologize Mr chair
who seconded that motion
prescription drug affordability
uh so Mr chair this is another rule that
we did receive a conditional approval
request on it did address uh pretty much
all of staff's comments except for one
substantive comment on page one
mid
401.01 L the definition for significant
morbidity
it's unclear how it's written it's
actually very confusing we had multiple
discussions and none of us could really
figure out what it meant so I had been
having numerous Communications with uh
the uh with Miss Kelly regarding the
definition and we have worked on a
potential compromise for this the only
problem is that the Midwifery Council
has already met this month they're not
meeting in November they won't meet
again until December and this is
something that would have to be run by
them prior to the change being made
so at this time the options of the
committee would be to either approve the
conditional approval as it's written
do a preliminary objection for which
time the council would have the
opportunity to do a response with regard
to fixing that or
um
postponing this item though if it's
postponed it will need a waiver
Mr Mr chair
there is one other option that is if the
committee initially approved it with the
change requested but with a realization
that the board might not agree with the
uh
language that's been worked out between
Tina Kelly and staff in which case if
they chose not to approve it then it
that seems to be the
correct route so my preliminary
objection
okay
representative hatch moves
to conditionally approve
we have a second
second by McGuire
I think I objected any discussion
and and the motion would include the
language that was discussed yes yes with
all
yes with all staff comments yeah
all those in favor
and
opl same electrologists
hey um so these rules are on
electrologists and electrology schools
and their licensing requirements
um on September 16th the committee voted
to enter a preliminary objection based
on staff comments and as part of that
vote included a recommend or a request
that the agency provide a report on the
mechanisms to fund activities during the
rules expiration
um so what you have in front of you is
the objection response and also a cover
letter we have a couple comments on the
cover letter as well the agency did not
address all of Staff comments and also
has
substantively amended the rule but not
in response to OLS comments
additionally the agency hasn't provided
a report of mechanisms mechanisms to
fund expenditures during the entire time
that the rule has been expired and the
rule has been expired since 2017. so
that's at a high level what's going on
with the um with the request first
if you look on page two of the cover
letter you'll see a large comment at the
top of the page
OLS we had commented previously on the
fact that the rule didn't have forms for
electrology schools to fill out and
noted that there was also no address in
the role for individuals to submit their
required information for licensing the
rule also stipulates that the
applicant's signature constitutes a
certification on the information that
they're going to submit but there's
nothing for a person to know that the
sheet of paper that they sign is going
to be their certification
so the agency's response hasn't resolved
that issue the agency created two
checklists and states that creating
forms wouldn't be a good way to expend
their resources so despite the fact that
the checklists don't contain a blank
space for the applicant to sign nine
there is still some concern that you
know that the applicant isn't on notice
that their signature is going to
constitute a certification and that the
um the checklist may be a type of form
because it is asking for confirmation
that certain things have been done by
the applicant
if you look on page
three of the linked PDF you'll see this
is a cover letter from the oplc in which
that last paragraph there they address
the fees that they have collected for
this past year
but as we noted the um the agency
statement doesn't address the collection
of fees since the rule expired in 2017.
now
um these rules were over at HHS and then
the laws of 2015 via House Bill 2 which
was effective in 2015 transferred that
authority over to the oplc and then the
rules expired in 2017.
but um let's see
the next comment is on page five of the
objection response
here um we had requested that the agency
delete this phrase for the purposes of
this chapter in two different
definitions we had initially made this
as an editorial comment and the agency
said that they did not want to take this
out because it's more clear but yet
having this language in these two
definitions kind of makes the other
definitions unclear whether or not they
actually apply to the entire chapter or
not because you're differentiating two
definitions and you're saying these two
definitions apply to the entire chapter
so that was the reason why we raised
that concern so that concern is still
present
and the location of the definitions
there at the beginning of chapter 1 700
that automatically means they're
applicable to the entire chapter
so the language is Superfluous to say
so um I'll skip uh the comments that
were editorial in nature that weren't
addressed just to save time
um the next comment I'm just scrolling
down here
is on page 20 of the PDF you'll see that
the agency has inserted some new
language
that's not in response to our comment
you may have some questions about that
we do note that the first couple of
changes there are most likely editorial
but the other two are not their new
language
the next comment I'm just scrolling down
is on page
25 of the PDF
the agency doesn't want to change the
language here to shall it says well not
the language says the executive director
shall notify the applicant or licensee
as applicable of deficiencies and
explain that the office will not approve
unless the deficiencies are corrected
the agency states that this isn't a
requirement and so it shouldn't be a
shall but the very next section says if
approval is denied pursuant to be above
it makes it pretty clear that that's
going to be a shell if there are
deficiencies and they they won't be
approved so that language really ought
to be shall
um then let's see like I said I'm going
to skip the editorial ones
the next one is on the next page 26 the
bottom of the page this section is where
we begin to see the insertion of a
checklist and
um
like we said before uh it's not clear
you know in what Manner or how or where
an applicant is supposed to submit this
stuff
oplc staff did indicate in the last
meeting that they were going to insert
an address either into a form or onto
the into the rule but that hasn't
happened so neither of these checklists
tell individuals how to submit the
required information it doesn't provide
any kind of contact information or
address and so that's one issue
and then if you look on the next page
again the owner's signature on the
request shall constitute certification
so um again
this hasn't resolved the issue of a
person having noticed that what they're
signing be it a piece of paper or
something that that constitutes a
certification and that's the same issues
again on page 28 and on page 29
also on page 29 there are some there are
some new language that wasn't in
response to comment that we note as well
let me skim through I think that those
thank you Mr chair for the record
Lindsay Courtney I'm the executive
director of The Office of professional
Ace insurance certification
um before I get into the specific
comments I just wanted to give you a
high level overview of how we ended up
here
um with expired rules for several years
obviously the committee is aware that
the electrology advisory committee
transfer transferred from DHHS to a PLC
I believe in 2018 via a house bill 2.
um at that time and for several years
thereafter the committee well advisory
in nature was essentially functioning as
an actual committee with complete
regulatory Authority that had been the
practice there had been deference given
to committee members
um in terms of moving things along and
making rule changes there was a
disagreement between the agency and the
advisory committee members as to how to
handle practical examinations which is
why at that time the rules were not
moved forward fast forward to 2020 the
agency has had a change of practice in
theory as it relates to advisory
committees and um
worked to obtain statutory changes which
we did this past year regarding the
administration of practical like
practical exams and that's why now
notwithstanding a disagreement between
the advisory committee and oplc we moved
these rules forward with respect to the
first issue regarding fees I think we
have addressed uh the committee's
concerns while the rules has been have
been expired since 2017 the fee was
actually set forth in statute we did
have clear statutory authority to
collect fees until July 1 of this year
when we worked with the legislature to
remove all statutory fees since July 1
of this year we have not collected a
single fee regarding electrology there
are only approximately 60 electrologists
so the fact that we haven't collected
that 110 dollar biennial fee is not
breaking the bank we are working with
the committee established by Senate Bill
230 to clarify
um or 3 30 to clarify oplc speed setting
Authority and I do anticipate bringing
some rules forward in the 1002s that'll
just collectively address uh the fee
setting issue until that time we we will
be able to pay our bills particularly
given the fact that the agency
historically lapses significant sums of
money to the general fund
regarding the substantive changes I
would disagree that any changes that
we've made are substantive of the bulk
of the comments that we received from
OLS were centered on not providing
sufficient clarification or notice to
the licensees any of the changes
including the changes I think referenced
on page 20 are are editorial in nature
in order to provide clarification in
response to this consensus that we
received for the OLS Commons regarding
um on page five for purposes of this
chapter
I'm happy to eliminate that I I disagree
that it creates an issue of substance I
do think it's editorial in nature
um but it for for our purposes happy to
eliminate that if that is the
committee's desire
regarding
um page 26 and the checklist
in practice we have never
had a mechanism for a school that's not
accredited to apply to be an approved
school that's just not something that
occurs however as part of establishing
our internal controls
we are became aware that we have a
statutory obligation to have a mechanism
apart from relying on accreditation to
have a pathway for someone to apply
I would be 99.9 sure that nobody will
ever exercise that option with the 60
electrologists that we have
um and the approved schools that already
exist additionally accreditation is
where electrologists receive a lot of
their continuing education and their
information they need to actually
perform their job so
um so I'm happy to create a form but
with one staff person focusing on agency
rules and the need to update a lot of
the agency rules to be reflective of our
statutory obligations I do not think
it's the best use of Staff resource time
if the committee disagrees we are happy
to go back in in Creative form
on the checklist issue I would note that
there is a clear direction as to what
one needs to do in order to apply there
is an address listed on the checklist
additionally and I know that the
committee may not be aware of this but
oplc is trying to finalize all of its
rules in draft form and one of the draft
sets that we will be filing hopefully
shortly will be the PLC 300s and those
will be the licensing procedures not
only for oplc but for all of the boards
it has taken us a little bit longer to
obtain comments from stakeholders and
feedback than we had thought so I had
anticipated that those would be before
you in some fashion prior to a
conclusion of the PLC 700s that will
address more specifically indiscreately
how all applications have to be filed so
from a practical standpoint I think that
that will address the issue
that said there is an address on the
checklist
um and then finally I did want to note
that there was a comment from OLS
regarding the agency's desire to not
incorporate uh forms into the rules but
rather to specify
the application requirements in the role
and I understand that there is an
expedited way
to modify a rule that's Incorporated by
reverence and that may be beneficial if
there needs to be some changes
but as the committee is aware there has
been a historic lack of internal
controls at the agency and at the board
level and what I have observed is that
in for many years board support staff
have changed and modified forms that
they were not allowed to do so to the
point that it was unclear what form was
actually approved by jail car and we had
to go to archives as a result of that
until we have finished our profiling
project that I've talked about
previously as well as establishing
internal controls I have requested that
all requirements be placed in rule
because that gives us an opportunity to
confirm that the application we are
sending to individuals or putting on our
website is actually what is
statutorially and legally required of us
to ask so that would be the response to
that OLS comment
once I've you know once we feel
satisfied that we have internal controls
in place maybe we can move in a
different direction but it's not at this
time thank you
if I could just follow up real quick so
there is an address in the header of the
checklist but there's nothing that
affirmatively tells the applicant that
they should send it there or to send it
to the board directly
um the there I would take issue with the
comment that some of these amendments
are editorial they are not for instance
on page 27 there's an entire new
sentence so I wouldn't think that that's
an editorial the agency May view it as
clean up but it certainly is a brand new
sentence there are other places that are
like that as well
um and uh let's see there was
um
as far as I'm not sure what statutory
Authority the oplc is relying on as far
as the fees are concerned
um like we said at the outset the the
paragraph on page three of the cover
letter only talks about the collection
of fees for the past year it doesn't
talk about the collection of fees during
the um the rules expiration I'm not sure
what Authority they would have been you
know collecting those fees under and I
don't see it referenced in the cover
letter
if I may that was addressed I agree that
there was statutory Authority that was
okay what's the recommended action by
could request a revised
um preliminary objection
um it sounds like the agency is willing
to to take out or to change some of the
language for instance
um this the language for this chapter
and the definitions the agency has noted
a few times in testimony that they're
willing to do a form instead of
checklist so you may want to give them
time to be able to do that so move
second
Ocean second
Mr chairman yes um for a revised
objection the agency acts has to make a
request of committee
I
I would think that their comments that
they're willing to make these changes
amounts to a request and I would movely
accept that request Lindsay
I I make the request consistent with the
committee's discussion thank you
discussion
we have a motion on a second all those
in favor
aye
and to wrap up today the Department of
thank you Mr chair starting with 2022
104.
uh this role
all three of the rules but this one
specifically
um
had been brought before the committee
previously and has been reworked a
couple of times at this point the only
comments remaining are some
inconsistencies between the rule and the
forms that were submitted to OLS
I have talked with attorney Wong
regarding those inconsistencies and he
has explained that the forms are
actually
edited and changed and posted by a third
party vendor So the agency's plan was to
revise the rules get the rules approved
first before going to the vendor and
having the vendor make those changes on
the forms
the agency is also Exempted under RSA
541a their forms are Exempted from the
rulemaking process so having them change
their forms outside of this process
wouldn't
um
violate any statutes at this time
with regard to the note on page 27 that
form was eventually submitted to LS
the comment on page 28 once again it's
an inconsistency between the form and
the rule this one was specifically noted
because it had to do with the
certification
in the rule this certification stated
that it had to be done by the majority
of the governing board or their
authorized designee while the form
stated that it was the finance director
or city manager that would certify the
form in discussion with the agency they
did state that they would change the
form to reflect the rule language as
they plan to do with their other forms
the other comment on page 28 once again
was specifically noted because
of the certification
um not being submitted with the form
so OLS was unable to see that
certification in conversations with the
agency it appears that that form it's an
online form that when you submit the
information
after you complete the form submit the
information then the certification page
pops up
so that's why it was not submitted to
OLS I have not seen that certification
page as it seems difficult for the
agency to provide it because of that
technological Nuance but that was all
yes move to approve second
discussion
seeing none all those in favor
next with regard to 2022 114 once again
this is one that has been before the
committee before it was sent back work
has been done to it so that the only two
remaining issues were there are a couple
comments starting on page two regarding
the authority legislative intent for the
agency to
seek or to request people submitting
their form signed under the Pains of
penalties of perjury as it's not
authorized by their statute the agency
has
stated to staff that they are going to
be seeking a legislative change
specifically to RSA 21j12 by adding a
new sub-paragraph D and attorney Wong
can correct me if this is in not being
stated correctly but the language that
they're proposing is developing such
forms or returns as may be necessary
which forms or returns may be required
to be signed under the pains and
penalties of perjury
staff's opinion on that language as it
would be sufficient to address this
issue
the other remaining comment on this rule
is on page four it's the unclear comment
with regard to the agency's use of the
word sufficient a conditional amended
conditional approval request was
submitted to our office reflecting
change to this language
specifically they would change
sufficient number of to enough
so that the statute or excuse me the
rule says enough stamps purchased within
the previous 90 days to pay the tax dual
cigarettes and little cigars present on
the premises at any given time
um changing that language
in staff's opinion would address our
comments
but if the committee has any additional
questions or wants to further explore
that language
that would be something staff would be
fine with go ahead
uh move to approve with the
addendum that the agency seek the
discussion
all those in favor
in Equalization of assessment for cities
towns unincorporated towns and
unorganized places
so staff also received a conditional
approval request to address the comments
and um
there was really only one comment with
regard to this Rule and that is the
incorporation of the equalization manual
into the rule
staff's comment was an authority
legislative intent comment because there
was a change in which board was actually
preparing that Equalization manual and
who on behalf of who they were creating
that manual so at this time it was in
the opinion of staff that the
particular board was doing it on behalf
of the agency and was administratively
tied to the agency and therefore the
manual should be
or could not be incorporated by
reference but had to be included in the
rules
after looking at the conditional
approval request
um seems as though that would not be
such an easy thing and between
discussions between the agency and staff
the better route to potentially take is
for the agency to instead seek a
legislative change to exempt the manual
from having to be incorporated in the
rules so exempting it from RSA 541a
and after discussion with the chair and
vice chair
it was determined that that may be the
better approach in that the conditional
approval request be denied at this time
and that the final proposal be voted on
with one minor change requested by the
agency
803.03 B uh the agency just asked that
that particular sentence be changed to
the department shall use the weighted
mean Ratio calculated to one-tenth of
one percentage and then deleting if the
weighted mean ratio with a 90 confidence
interval does not straddle 1.00 this is
not a huge substantive change and would
not really affect the final proposal
um
so staff didn't have any comments with
regard to that Angie's with regard to
that agency that suggestion by the
agents
yes I recommend we conditionally approve
the final Proposal with that uh that
change and
request the agency to request a
legislative change to incorporate the
next
discussion
all those in favor
any opposed
attorney Wong you're the star of the day
Mr chairman for your business would the
committee uh like to uh not have its uh
continue meeting
yeah
there doesn't seem to be any necessity
of that
any other business
well I always say at the beginning that
the conditional Amendment so this one
was amended thank you all for your
okay